welcome to the show I am ready today I
actually showered this morning I never
take showers in the morning but because
I was up early I figured let's do a even
better show today I will take a shower
in the morning my hair is groomed I'm
ready to go and we're gonna start by
talking about climate change you
probably have heard this phrase that's
thrown around 97 to 3 the scientific
consensus is that climate change is real
or that humans are causing or affecting
climate change it's always a little bit
vaguely defined in colloquial speech
when people mention that it's not clear
whether we mean 3 percent of climate
scientists deny climate change or 3
percent of climate scientists deny that
climate change is caused by humans or
that it's 3 percent of papers but some
other percentage of the scientists so 3
percent first of all refers to papers
not scientists and often the anti
science right will point to that 3
percent and say look there have been
minority opinions in the past that have
ultimately been vindicated heliocentrism
right the Sun at the center of our solar
system for example and of course it's
pretty bogus the reality is that most
scientists agreed with heliocentrism to
take it as an example but organized
religion was significantly opposed to
the theory at a general level this also
ignores that science today functions
much differently than it did in the past
but let's forget that for now right
we've got this infrastructure of what's
called peer-reviewed scientific papers
and a peer-reviewed study was done of
those 3 percent of papers that cast
doubt on the consensus of climate change
and this is a study called
learning from mistakes and climate
research it was published actually about
10 months ago in the journal called
theoretical and applied climatology and
they found major problems with that 3%
of all studies into climate change this
sort of meta study or or attempt to
verify other studies they tried to
replicate those 3% of studies and they
figured out that a lot of those studies
flat out had
methodological flaws in other words the
way that a lot of those studies that
cast doubt on to climate change were
done did not meet the scientific rigor
and standards that one would want many
of the papers that deny climate change
as a result of the systemic flaws in how
the papers were done have results that
actually point to artifacts in the data
as a result of how the experiments were
set up rather than any actual
counter-argument to climate change and
climate change being caused by human
activity on earth and a lot of times
they also identify false dichotomies or
bad statistical methods basically it's a
total indictment that the three-percent
might be right it appears that the 3%
that cast doubt on to climate change are
doing really really bad science and it
seems quite nefarious - and you take a
look at it because these studies had
three major flaws one was that they
would cherry-pick information right
another was that they used inappropriate
curve fitting and they also just ignored
physical realities so it sounds as if
they're starting with their conclusion
and trying to work backwards rather than
using the scientific method which is the
other way around and this is not a huge
shock right a good question to be asking
would be how is this stuff even getting
published in peer-reviewed journals in
the first place and that's actually a
major topic in the scientific world
right now and the explanation is mostly
what we would expect you've got a lot of
low quality journals that have a very
low standard for what they'll publish
you have people in some cases that are
using personal connections and cronyism
to get their research published and then
you also have some errors from the peer
reviewers and the reason that this
should worry all of us is that the peer
review method is supposed to be the gold
standard of solid science right we have
many many papers on the subject of
climate change that just have glaring
errors in the way the studies were done
and you would hope that the peer review
system would catch that but it didn't in
a lot of these cases and I want to be
totally transparent with you there's
probably many studies in the 97%
consensus on climate change
that also have some methodological
problems or might not be replicable
that's just a reality
what should really anger us about all of
this is that we've got a crisis in our
environment here on earth and rather
than devoting all of our energy and
resources to solving the problem we have
to spend at least some time debunking
bad science and trying to explain why
the climate skeptics are wrong and
beyond that even if climate changes a
myth can't we all agree that there are
many other good reasons to stop pumping
tons of pollution into the air including
disease related to pollution how it
affects animals and thus our food supply
on and on and so forth why is it that we
should just ignore everything we're
doing to our planet
if you can't definitively connect human
activities to climate change which by
the way you can well it just sounds like
you might have ulterior motives then
because I don't think there's some
international conspiracy of 97% of
scientists who just think that it's all
you know made up to get grant money or
something like this yet right what would
be the incentive to concoct this
conspiracy theory of course Alex Jones
have some ideas I won't even repeat them
now because that's not what this program
is about but why would there be such a
conspiracy is it to hurt the oil baron's
I mean come on it seems like the
incentive would be on the other side so
you can get a nice cushy job with the
oil industry and continue making money
by pillaging the resources of our planet
absolutely horrible and really important
study the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership